when did you know like fighting was your
thing to do you know not at that moment
but I um I was very sick as a kid so I
was bullied a lot I had a horrible skin
disease I was the leper in school that's
what they called me uh and needless to
say uh you know you start building an
aggression towards these bullish because
it went on a daily basis and then when I
was 12 years old I saw a Bruce Lee movie
sneaked in started learning martial arts
took two years actually to convince my
parents but once I did it for two and a
half months I knocked the first bully
out the biggest one in my school
and that's when I realized wow this is
actually pretty easy because it was
Taekwondo what I did it was only kicking
but somehow I knocked at one point she
was out the problem was he broke his
nose in the process
so the police showed up and I confirmed
for my mom and dad that it was violence
and so they took me off martial law so
then I had to wait uh till I was 20 when
I moved out of the house and that's
immediately I started doing correct so
14 20 you're doing nothing oh no I am of
course I slipped in you know illegally
you know going to places watching
videotapes